You know that feeling when you make a casual 6 billion dollars in a day?
Yeah, neither do we.
But our Facebook friend Mark Zuckerberg does...
...and it seems like the number 6 is a lucky one for Facebook's founder.
After raking in 6 billion bucks on Thursday...
...he rose to the sixth richest person in the world.
And he has you, me, and the other 1.59 billion Facebook users logging on...
...each month to thank for that.
Facebook reported very strong results for the fourth quarter Wednesday.
Ad sales were up 57% over the previous year's numbers in the last three months of 2015.
Needless to say, that sent shares of the company soaring.
According to CNBC, a Facebook share rose more than 15% in a day.
Zuckerberg's current net worth now stands at about 47 billion dollars.